Did you have trouble crossing under this bridge
in Chapter 2?
Well here’s a trick that allows any build to get across:
Kick-spamming.
This technique
is useful in so many situations.
I think this is by far
the most energy efficient way
to cover a distance in Armored Core 6
It can save you.
If you're about to fall off a stage,
it can get you across vast distances.
It can get you higher than you'd otherwise
be able to go.
So definitely consider this, especially
if you're equipped with tank treads.
I think their kick gets you the furthest.
Speaking of kicks, you might have noticed
that kicks don't just do impact damage.
They deal direct damage as well.
And while you might think that leg type
would play a part
in direct damage or impact dealt,
it doesn't.
However, the direct damage of your kick
is affected by something.
It's affected by the weight of your AC,
For example, this is a kick
with a lightweight AC and here's a kick
with the heaviest tank I could make.
What's also interesting
is that kicks do roughly three times
as much damage to enemies
when they're staggered,
which is a much bigger multiplier
than most other weapons have combined.
This with the fact that you can spam kicks
pretty fast.
This can be a really lethal tool,
especially if you have nothing else
to do while reloading.
And on some enemies like tetrapod empties,
you can extend
the duration of their stagger
if you kick them during this state.
So if you haven't worked kicks into your
playstyle yet, absolutely do that.
But let's be honest.
More important
than anything else in this video
is your fashion,
your armor decor, so to speak.
And one key part of your fashion
is your booster color,
because did you notice that booster color
isn't determined by the booster part.
Instead, it's
actually determined by your generator.
For example,
this generator gives me a blue booster,
which actually turns
my gold AC like an ugly green.
This one gives a nice default orange,
which is better.
But this coral generator gives me this
awesome red color.
And even though it has a recharge delay
of like 5 seconds,
you know, I'm still going to use it.
Speaking of fashion, though,
this is my LG Corporation, AC
and I made this because LG are actually
our corporate sponsor for this video.
So I wanted to do a video with LG
because uniquely among Fromsoftware
games, Armored Core 6
actually has amazing widescreen support.
So LG sent over one of their ultrawides
for me
to show you guys,
and I was absolutely blown away.
This, I think, is unironically the best
way to play Armored Core, in my opinion.
The curved screen just makes this game
so immersive,
and having a wide field of view
is legitimately incredible
for your situational awareness
because you can see
all of the enemies around you
while you're fighting.
So this is the LG Ultra Gear OLED 45GR95QE
Sounds like it could be a part in game.
It's a 45 inch 21 by nine
display with a clean, really
borderless design and also a crazy fast
0.03 millisecond response time,
which makes it perfect for gaming.
The also touting this as the world's
first 240 hertz gaming monitor.
If you're interested in
investing in one for yourself,
check out the link in the description.
And thank you to LG
for sponsoring this video number five.
If you ever run out of energy in the air,
you are extremely vulnerable.
You can't dodge or fly
or you can do is fall.
But did you know that
falling directly down
is actually the best thing you can do
in this situation?
A lot of the time
when you push forward on the left
analog stick,
as long as your boosters are toggled
on, you'll still float
somewhat horizontally,
even when you're completely out of energy.
Note our speed while we're doing this.
However, if you let go of the left, stick
completely,
your boosters will deactivate
and you'll end to freefall mode.
In this state, you'll fall a lot faster,
even though
it says your boosters are still on
just look at the speed difference.
Therefore, free falling straight down
can actually make
you way more avoidant of projectiles
coming your way,
especially if you're falling perpendicular
to the shot that's coming your way.
So consider doing this as a last resort.
Next time you run out of energy.
Number 6:
So target assist can be great.
It gives you unparalleled
focus on single enemies
and it makes it way easier for you
to focus on dodging and flying.
But it's actually not
the optimal way to play.
That's because when you toggle on target
assist, your tracking strength is actually
compromised and less of your shots
will find their mark as a result.
This is absolutely something
you can feel in the gameplay
and you might have even noticed
how much more your reticle
lags behind
when you're locked on in this way.
But the question is
how bad is this effect?
How much is your tracking strength
compromised when using target assist?
Let's try to figure it out.
So there are a lot of variables that make
this really hard to test in a vacuum.
We have to ensure that our enemy is moving
in pretty much the exact
same way at the exact
same speed, at the exact same distance
with target assist toggled on
and then off.
So I came up with this.
The jump test. With this, distance
and movement become controlled variables
and we can really try to narrow
down the difference in accuracy
with target assist toggled on and off.
Here's what I found.
So at 50 meters with target assist
of 0.018% of my shots missed
compared to 12% of my shots
missing with target assist
at 100 meters with target assist off
27% of my shots missed
compared to 47% with target assist
and at 150 meters with target assist off,
it was 44%
compared to 61% with target assist.
And then at 200 meters, 55% of my shots
missed without it
and 74% missed with target assist.
So just at a glance from that data,
target assist is clearly having
a big impact here.
In many cases, almost twice as many of my
shots missed while using target assist.
Now, admittedly,
I didn't get like a huge sample size here
and I only tested this with one weapon,
so I'd really like to invite someone
better than me to perform
the jump test more thoroughly.
If I find someone who does
a really good experiment online, I'll
pin their results in the comments
section below.
But for now, I think it's safe to say that
you really should be trying to learn
to play without target assist if you can,
especially if your enemy is small
and agile.
For number seven,
let's talk about these gaps
So often advice
I give when building an AC is
to try and stay as close
to your maximum loads as possible.
This will ensure that you're packing
on the most value
that your legs and generator can support.
That said,
there are benefits to leaving gaps here
that you might not know about in regards
to your maximum load.
A larger gap
will contribute towards your boost speed.
So notice how my boost speed becomes
faster when I just unequipped my weapons.
That's because leftover load
contributes to your speed.
You can even achieve this boost
to your speed by purging weapons
during a mission.
What's interesting is that a similar logic
applies to your EN load as well.
The larger the gap, the faster
your energy bar will recharge.
That's because leftover
EN output contributes
towards your supply efficiency stat.
The higher this value, the faster
your energy bar will move
after the recharge delay.
Just look at this difference now.
It's really cool that the game rewards
your excess like this,
but I will say in my experience,
the benefits of having a large gap
still don't really outweigh the benefits
of just stacking on better parts instead.
For example,
your energy is coming back fast
either way, you know,
but it's a nice thing to have for sure.
Another thing that's really nice to have
is the hanger bay upgrade in your own
tuning screen.
This allows you to store
two more arm parts on your back.
Note,
however, that you can't fire these weapons
when they're stored in the hanger.
Instead, L1 and R1 will just switch
to these weapons for your arms instead.
And when you first think about it,
that seems kind of bad, right?
After all, wouldn't you just want to fire
four weapons at once?
Isn't that more DPS than just two?
However, consider this weapons
that overheat can cool down in the hanger.
Weapons can even reload
while they're in the hanger.
So just think about how good that is.
With this technique,
you can offset the downside of some of
the strongest weapons in the game.
Fire your chain guns to overheat
and then switch to shotguns
while they cool down in the hanger.
Break guards with the pile bunker
melee weapon, then
pull out a sword to capitalize on that
while it cools down.
Or just equip four machine guns and switch
them out whenever you need to reload.
This way
your DPS is absolutely unrelenting,
and I unironically think after
testing a lot of this stuff that hang
builds will end up being
some of the strongest builds in the game.
Anyway, speaking of OS upgrades,
do you regret any of the OS upgrades
you've invested in?
Well, don't worry, because by
pressing triangle or Y in this menu
you can undo each upgrade
you've purchased for 4000 credits.
One reason I did my points
is because I realized that
the most efficient way to invest
your points is actually to invest
in the lowest tier of many upgrades
rather than going deep into just one.
That's
because the lowest tiers are the cheapest.
So it's kind of best
to buy all the low tiers first.
Number ten.
This next trick is particularly good
when you're fighting an enemy AC.
Though I'll admit it's a pretty high
skill cap thing to do,
and that's melee canceling.
So by tapping quick boost
right at the end of your melee boost,
you're able to cancel your melee boost
and immediately initiated again,
creating a loop
where you're constantly moving, closing
in on and threatening the enemy.
AC Without even overheating your weapon.
This is particularly good
if you've chosen a booster
that has a really good melee attack
thrust and a melee attack in consumption
spec, as these can enable you
to close the gap
between enemies more effectively
than even an assault boost could.
It also looks cool as hell.
That's kind of the main reason
to do this, honestly.
But the coolest thing you can do
in Armored Core is s-ranking missions
according to the game
to achieve an S rank rating.
You must complete the mission
without retrying from a checkpoint
while also minimizing incoming damage,
time taken and ammunition consumed.
In practice, though,
it's actually not that simple.
For example, in the mission, destroy
the transport helicopters.
I finished the objectives extremely fast
without taking a point of damage
and only got an eight rank to achieve an S
rank.
I realized it helped a lot
to actually kill some enemies as well.
The game doesn't tell you
that you need to kill enemies,
but that is important apparently.
And then for certain missions
it seems like the s rank criteria are
weighted differently.
For example, in a chapter two mission,
I destroyed the smart cleaner
very quickly,
but I used dual Gatling guns to do it.
And even though I didn't die, I achieved
a really low rank for some reason
for this mission, it seems ammunition
cost counted against me greatly.
And then there was this mission
where I took a ton of damage,
and I was sure that I did terribly.
And then I got an AC rank.
Turns out this mission has an extremely
high tolerance for the damage you take.
So my takeaway from all of this
is that while it's certainly possible
to s rank by focusing on
just doing one thing, well,
there are missions where it feels like
some things matter more than most.
So definitely
try and switch up your build and strategy
if you're not having much success.
Build for speed or kills or low ammunition
cost or low damage
taken and see how you go.
Prioritizing different things.
But what's the reward for ranking
every mission in the game, you ask?
Well, it makes you feel good.
According to my review guide, you get a
trophy and an achievement and that's it.
Which I'll admit
is a little bit disappointing.
I wish there was some incentive, but
I guess it's
more about the journey in the end.
One of the metrics for s ranking missions
is, again,
not being wasteful with your ammunition.
So you might think that reloading manually
and just throwing away
the entire rest of the magazine
would be wasteful, right?
Wrong.
Because video game
laws are in effect here.
And when you reload an armored core six,
your magazine will magically
fill with the exact amount of ammunition
you need.
Despite
that kind of being physically impossible,
that means that you only really need
to worry about
the ammunition that you fire in a mission
and nothing more.
Being wasteful is a pretty fast way
to rack up some debt in armored core six.
Though
admittedly, incurring debt is quite rare.
Even if you're firing
the most expensive weaponry.
This is the most debt I could get
when I tried.
For example.
I just quickly wanted to confirm
that yeah, it is possible to go negative
in the mission and lose money, though
no matter how much you waste or lose,
it's impossible to actually go negative in
terms of your total funds in the garage.
Speaking of firing ammunition,
there are many situations
where you might want to consider
staggering your fire
rather than unloading all at once.
For example, when fighting a fast opponent
like an enemy AC,
it's very likely that they'll dodge
your attacks, especially your missiles.
So for example, if you unload
two sets of missiles at them at once,
they can just easily negate
both of those salvos with one dodge.
Instead, what you should do is fire
one after the other with a short delay.
This way you're far more likely
to catch them during or
after a dodge
with at least one set of missiles.
The same applies to weapons with a slow
firing rate.
Take dual shotguns, for example.
If I fire both at once,
they're both liable to miss.
But if I fire one after the other,
even if I miss one,
the second is far more likely to connect.
Spacing out
your shots also makes it less likely
that enemies will get a chance
to recover their ACS build up,
which is what can happen
if they go too long without taking damage.
Next, I believe that there are just
two status effects in Armored Core 6:
ACS anomaly and electrical discharge.
However, the game doesn't really explain
what these are, so I'll try.
ACS anomaly is built up over time with fire
based attacks.
When the bar fills completely,
you'll receive this warning,
which lasts for about 10 seconds.
During this time, the impact damage
you receive is significantly increased.
Compare this, for example,
to this.
And while we're looking at the staggered
gauge, it's important to note
that the metal bar is easier to fill up
than the outer bars.
Essentially, it seems like this middle
section counts as one bar
and filling
the outer two bars takes twice as long.
There are two bars on the outside
after all, so effectively
it seems like ACS anomaly increases
the impact
damage
you take by about 50% for 10 seconds,
which makes it really quite
an impactful status effect.
The other status effect in AC
six is the shock status effect,
which I figured out is essentially bleed
from other from soft games.
Basically what happens is
when you take electrical damage,
your elec discharge bar will fill doing
a burst of damage once at the end
when the bar is completely filled.
What's interesting about this
shock effects in this game, though, is
that it's actually not percentage based
damage unlike bleed from previous games.
Regardless of your AP,
this effect seems to do a flat
1600 damage,
meaning shock will kind of naturally
be better against lightweight aces
rather than heavy ones.
Of course, you can build up status effects
on other enemies as well,
even non AC enemies like MT’s.
Though it's worth noting that clearly
some enemies have more resistance
than others and some bosses effectively
seem immune to status effects entirely.
Now that kind of is a third status effect,
although it's strictly not one as well.
It's the smoke bomb, which has an effect
that creates a little bubble,
a little zone.
And while you're inside this zone,
you can't lock on to enemies outside it
and they can't lock on to you
if you're inside it either.
However, if you're both inside the zone,
then you can lock onto each other.
And if the smoke is in between
both of you, it actually acts
like a piece of terrain.
Would it blocks you from locking onto
the enemy at a distance as well?
Essentially, this is really cool,
but as its description states,
it's going to take a lot of finesse
to effectively use this in combat.
If there are more status effects
in the game I haven't listed, I apologize.
I'm playing through the game
really thoroughly,
but I'm playing through
really slowly as well.
I've only just finished chapter three,
so it's possible that there's more
that I'm missing.
Number 16 canceling this is only mentioned
very briefly in training.
So remember pressing triangle or Y
will allow you to cancel certain actions.
For example,
if you're charging a weapon and no longer
want to charge it,
just press triangle or Y.
And if you've started a multi lock
that you regret, you can also
press triangle
or Y to revert to a single lock.
Now, I'm kind of shocked that this next
tip isn't in the official tutorial,
and that's that in most situations it's
not optimal to cancel your assault boost
by pulling back on the left
stick like the tutorial tells you to do.
Doing this
actually brings you to an abrupt halt,
which can easily get
you killed instead, by pushing forward
on the left stick
and just tapping the send button.
You're able to cancel your assault, boost
and maintain
your forward momentum,
which is just objectively better.
Number 18.
So unlike in other from soft games,
you can't actually load
multiple saves in the main menu.
You can only have one playthrough
active at any time.
So be careful of that new game
button this time around
since it will overwrite your current safe.
I can kind of see why they made it
this way.
The game is designed around
replaying missions and going into new game
plus after all.
One thing that oddly does seem to persist
if you start
a new game is your AC data
from your previous save.
If you didn't know in this menu,
you can quickly build
your old saved AC designs though
of course you still need their parts.
I'd also quickly like to mention
that you can upload your AC designs
in this menu as well.
This will give you a code to share with
others who might want to create your AC.
Here's the code for my LG AC though
this doesn't seem to work cross-platform.
The same goes for Emblem Designs
while you're in the garage.
One thing not many people realize you can
do is enter photo mode while you're here.
Here you can fly your camera around
quite far
and explore the little container
that you're a stowaway within.
And of course, the same photo mode can be
activated while you're out on a mission
during the pause menu.
Another small thing,
but there are situations
where you really should use the compass
and the radar that's built into it.
In this mission, for example, it's
important for me to head towards enemies
as soon as they appear and my radar
is the best way of doing that.
What's more,
lots of information shows up down
here, like target objectives and more.
These little arrows for example,
also indicate
if an enemy is above or below
you in that direction.
If you're on your first attempt
or don't care at all about
ranking a mission, consider
simply restarting from check points
as soon as you notice
that you've reached one.
For example, here
I've taken so much damage that there's
just no way I'm going to beat Sula
in this upcoming fight.
It would be a waste of my time.
Instead, as soon as I noticed
this indicator in the bottom right,
I can just manually start
from the checkpoint and fully restore
my AP
and my repair packets. For number 22,
Remember that your standard repair
kit heals a flat 4000 AP So when healing,
try to make sure that you've taken
4000 damage before healing it.
And when building an AC,
consider that you functionally have
12,000 more
AP than what it's showing you on screen.
So when you think about your functional
AP and keep healing in mind
the difference between a heavyweight
AC with a lot of AP
and a lightweight
AC with not much AP, the difference
between them gets smaller
when you take into account
that both builds have 12,000
HP on top of what they already have.
That said, repair kits
aren't a thing in the arena,
so I think that heavy ACS really
will benefit
from their raw AP and defensive stats
a lot more.
They're just one extra thing when you fall
off the map in armored classics.
You don't take a flat AP punishment.
Instead, falling off
the map will take 35% of your total AP.
Let's talk about some of the lesser used
OS tuning upgrades.
One of the worst kind of has to be access
speed optimization,
which increases your interaction
speed by 50% and then 100%.
This can be useful,
but it's extremely situational.
For example,
some missions might have you hack
something while you're in firing range.
It's pretty good then.
So I'd definitely consider this upgrade
to be great for ranking certain missions,
but other than that,
I rank it as a pretty low priority.
One little secret you might have missed
with this, though, is that
objects have different
scan levels associated with them.
I've found three scan levels so far,
and the higher that they're stored LV is,
the longer they will take to access
another arguably less important OS tuning
upgrade is the quick turn,
which when unlocked, allows you
to do a 90 degree or a 180 degree
turn of your mic and the camera
by holding circle or B and turning
your left stick in the desired direction.
In any other Armored Core game,
this would be incredible.
But in Armored Core 6  it's
kind of just all right.
The best thing about it is that it moves
your camera faster than you can.
Even with camera speeds
set to ten, though,
those playing with mouse and keyboard
actually won't have this problem at all.
It's worth unlocking this
if you play with a controller
and if you play without target assist.
But I feel like most players
can confidently give this one a miss.
Another very neat OS
upgrade is weight control,
which lets you enter missions overweight
and manually purge your weapons.
Being over your weight
limit seems to penalize your speed
in a similar way to how being under
your weight limit rewards your speed.
So going into a mission overweight
really isn't the worst thing in the world.
The best use case I could think of for
this would be
when you use it in tandem
with its manual purge function.
This way you could enter a mission
with heavy weaponry.
You could use up those weapons
and then you could purge them
if you no longer have a use for them.
So the best use case I could think of for
that was to bring in heavy snipers.
Use them at a safe range where
your lack of speed doesn't really matter.
Then purge them and get in close
with your faster AC.
What's also cool is that you'll
get these weapons back after
you've purged them at a resupply station,
so you will be able to have them back
for difficult boss encounters
at the end of the mission.
And if you do go with this purging
strategy,
consider choosing an arm part
with a high melee specialization step.
This will increase the damage
of your punches, but so far for me,
haven't really been able to build around
weight control in a meaningful way.
Maybe later in the game I'll unlock
some parts that make that viable.
So I'm curious
if you guys have any ideas for that.
But that's it.
Before I go again, think about investing
in an ultrawide monitor for your setup.
It's so good. Links in the description.
Thanks again
to LG for sponsoring this video.
Forget BALAM
Forget ARQUEBUS
Thank you.
LG and I'll see you all next time.